okay so thank you very much to the
organizers I'm very happy to be there so
the the focus in this talk will be on a
model of which conditioner of a model of
piece of conductive material with the
macroscopic homogenate inhomogeneity so
the microscopic inhomogeneities utilized
by random small random resistances so
you equip the lattice CD with the IID
random resistances and make an
assumption of ellipticity on it so this
means that they are uniformly bounded
away from zero and infinity here between
1 and lambda say the content the
individual conductances is just the
reciprocal values of the resistances and
you you imagine your piece of material
as a large box in DD so let's take 0
into the G and you you wonder what is
the effective resistance through the box
that is what is the effective resistance
through to opposite sides let's say a
and in the end here so the effective
resistance can be defined as the minimum
of the ended of the energy of a flow
going from A & tues en overall unit
flows from a n to the N and the what is
the unit flow for me n to the N it is
something it is a function defined a
real function defined on the edges
anti-symmetric what goes through one
edge is the opposite of what goes a tus
image in the other direction and it
satisfies the knot law everywhere except
at both sides so and what what enters
the network at a n is 1 and net flow
outside the network at Gianni's one
the left yes here a n is the left side
so when they're identified with zero yes
here it's equivalent to say that there
they are they are the same voltage
identified as vertex okay so when you
you see that model you the natural
question for probability is what is the
what is the asymptotic behavior when n
goes to infinity of that kind of thing
so first let us understand what is the
order of this effective resistance and
to see to see this I first let us let us
call it the reciprocal value of the
resistance the effect of the effective
resistance the effective conductance or
the box no any distribution between 1
and lambda but I addy
so the the the reciprocal value of the
rate of the effective resistance also
has a version of formula it is the
minimum of the energy the kind of
directly energy dissipated on the on the
box so the energy is just the
conductance the energy across an edge is
the conductance times the voltage drop
squared and you minimize / functions
which are now on the vertices and which
have the boundary conditions to be zero
on a n in one on da so in fact it's the
complete agreement with the last slide
it would be better to say one on a and
in zero is even better anyway and the
minimum is attained at a unique function
which is the unique harmonic function on
the Box everywhere except that about ad
at side a and ZN and which satisfy the
boundary condition so here harmonic
function means that when you have the
weights given by the conductances it
means that these harmonic at x is
equivalent they signify that the sum of
all ages starting from X of c of e times
V of e minus minus V of B plus equals 0
it means that V is is the mean at some
point it is the mean but wait the
weighted mean of of the orphids values
on the neighbors waited by the
connections so it has it harmonic
everywhere except at the side so to
understand the order of CN there is a
very simple candidate to be
minimizer let let us call it V home it's
just the home of x is just x 1 over n so
this this is equal to zero on a n + 1 on
the N and in fact it is the true
minimizer when all conductance is equal
to 1 and so you see that then this this
zone here equals is of order n to the D
times 1 over N squared so it's of order
n to the D minus 2 ok and because of the
evolution of formulation you can compare
CN of any of residences if resistances
are in 1 lambda you can compare it to
the to the homogenous CN and so for any
collection of resistances in 1 lambda
you have that the effective conductances
of order and to the de- to so enter the
de- to should be the right order and so
the effective resistance is of order and
to the two major C so there is a lot of
large number which is known since the
80s rigorously in this context you to
cause love and in fact it is part of a
much larger theory which is called
homogenization theory and which has been
developed notably by Papanikolaou
n'varda she cough Kozlov another unique
and cleaner man in a discrete setting
and the it is much larger notably
because you can do in order to obtain
the law of large number you can you can
only suppose that the resistances are a
gothic translation invariance and a good
okay so but let let us stick to the case
where the resistances are iid in order
to go a step further in the analysis of
the of the asymptotic probabilistic
behavior of the resistor
the effective resistance and let us try
to understand the order of fluctuations
of the effective resistance so there was
never bond in the 90s by there which
showed that the violence is at least I
mean it translates slightly to this but
it was not stated it was on the
effective conductance in fact but anyway
it translates like to this so it says
that the violence is at least of the
order of n 2 4 minus 3 D and just to
understand this a lower bond in the
lower bond that you would obtain if you
supposed sorry if you support here that
this V was just V homogeneous so if this
if this effective conductance was only
assume of iid consequences then the
violence would translate on the
effective resistance as n to the
four-minute 3d more recently there was a
result by Gloria and auto which gave an
optimal estimation for the violence but
not really for the effective resistance
but for something which is called the
correct on which is which comes from
homogenization theory and which has the
advantage to be translation translation
environment but what so it is not
exactly what we want but they had a good
a good notion of a good result on the
violence of of something related to the
effective resistance and is there a
central limit theorem then we can wonder
if if iron is asymptotically goshen once
correctly normalized and there are so we
will address this question and there are
two main lead to other result 1 by Nolan
which are gets a Gaussian approximation
Anderson's some hypotheses and another
one by biskup Servian Wharf if I have
some time I will
like I can maybe compare the results in
the end of the talk so the conjecture is
as follows the the lower bon viveur
should be the right order and once we
normalized the effective resistance
should be approximately Goshen I don't
know how to prove precisely this result
so the the main result four of the top
would be to show that it is true on the
torus sorry oh yeah for g equals one I
know how to prove this ok so the in the
first part I will just forget the
setting of the box and look at the
general countable network with bounded
degree and try to understand what what
we can say about the the fluctuations of
the the effective resistance and it may
be a Gaussian approximation on it so G
will be a countable oriented symmetric
and connected graph with 90 degree the
fact that so it is symmetric it's just
for notational reasons in fact so ass so
see me it since it is oriented is just
that I a lobe in fact both edges occur
in both in both directions every every
edge occurs in both direction in E but
then i define year even have to be just
one of the orientation asst each other
coach with one of them and then I I take
some deterministic for the moment
elliptic resistances and the edges and I
want to to to precise a bit the flow
what I call a flow so I give a name to
the energy if theta is an anti-symmetric
on the function on the edges I call ER
theta the energy dissipated on the
network and we called estar the boundary
operator which takes a flow or function
on the edges and gives a function on the
vertices digital data at X is just the
net flow going out at of X so we take
that theta is the flow from u to V
essentially I already told her the thing
of intensity I if in fact it did start
it is zero everywhere I except maybe
except at U and V and equals I at you
and minus I a tree so this is this means
that node low is satisfied except at U
and V now we need the notion of current
a flow I from u to V is a current if it
satisfies so in addition to being a flow
if it satisfies the cycle loop that is
what every oriented cycle ein the
voltage drop along that cycle is 0 this
is equivalent to say that one may write
I when we I'm this is equivalent to the
fact that I derives from a potential so
that there exists some function V on the
vertices so that are half e times I of V
equals the voltage drop along along a G
now yes in the smaller market that the
fact should be this d thing when when I
derive some potential the fact that
these harmonic at x is equivalent to the
fact that I is satisfies the not low
effects of X so now we I recall the the
notation the effective resistance
between two vertices U and V is that the
infimum of the energy dissipated by flow
theta overall unit frosty
star from u to V so the infimum is
uniquely attained even in this countable
setting because you are minimizing a
hilbert norm over a closed subset and
and we shall call it i Sabbah to UV so
it and in fact it is it is a current
which is called the minimal your unit
current from you to be so record nitro
question what is the order of the
violence and can we say something of
their about a Gaussian approximation and
the start of the effective resistance
but u and v are arbitrary vertices and
in fact i would like to to understand if
we can bound the violence of the of the
effective resistance maybe I'm sorry the
resistances they were deterministic but
now i will take them independence and
random variables independent in in 1
lambda let's say so this this becomes a
random variable no i understand that i
say i don't even understand how this
resistance I don't understand the first
order how it depends on the distance
between U and V okay it depends on the
graph you if we if so I'm not saying
that i will give you a universal bound
for any graph but i want to understand
mainly how the effective resistance
scripture is ok you may be the you would
see later in fact what we will show i
can say too yes but i don't know the
first moment is too dependent on the
vector on the on the graph what i want
but i will show it that's the first
moment is not
the randomness so if you just ate
resistance is one you get some order by
the ebay the frustration will not change
only change so the order you know of
their existence just by putting
deterministic resistances but the
variance is a real mystery and so just
another comment so to match the variants
lower bound from before before we make
the Torres okay some it's possible a
test function current could give the
right order because if you choose that
inappropriate flow that gives an upper
bound and resistance on the resistance
but the violence is a it doesn't tell
you something on the vines yes but for
the lower bound you said it was a test
function for the conductance for
potential and for the lower but not on
the violence for the rubber band of the
of the rest the effective resistance so
the 12 the thesaurus the strategy is to
use the the wash decomposition as they
introduced by I made a time here in the
first talker effect this workshop so I
will return you briefly what what I need
for from the wash decomposition so let
us take a structure square integrable
function on the of the resistances of
the correction of the resistances so I
just suppose that the low for the moment
that the law of the resistances are it
is a correspond to an independent
collection of resistances it is a
product law so the watch the composition
of F is to write it as a sum over all
finite subsets s of the edges of F sub s
where F sub s are functions will just
depend only on the resistances inside
the subset s and they can be written as
as follows if I call Delta
f-this the Delta is the following
operator it Maps F to F minus its mean
against coordinate e it is kind of
discrete derivative you can view it like
this but then FS can be expressed as the
conditional mean given our our service
of the product of the Delta e for in s
apply to it so here you should think of
this as a partial derivative essentially
roughly a partial derivative with
respect to all the resistances which are
in s okay so as we saw with Hamid in
Hammonds talk Delta essentially that
Delta e f is the sum of a mess of all
sets s which contain edge e okay this is
just because that because this if you
integrate this over an edge which does
not belong to two asset it just remains
the same and one so this is since this
is an orthogonal projection and it I oh
yes smt is just a constant okay since it
depends on nothing and it is so it is
the necessarily the mean of F and so if
you want to compute the violence you
just have to compute the sum of the l2
norm squared of F s 4 s not empty this
is of course always smaller than the sum
of all set s of the Cardinal first time
the l2 norm of F s squared and this just
by interchange using this formula and
interject interchanging to Psalms is the
so overall HD of the tune of the tire
square so this is in this context
violence of F less than this it is it
might be cold
the progeria in equality activities of a
kind but this this will be useful
because the violence of F we are looking
to understand the violence of F notably
and this can be easily evaluated in
terms of a mean of something which input
it involves the optimal flow the current
the mini microphone so what we will show
is twofold I'm sorry after now thank you
so what we will show is twofold first in
fact uniformly in you envy and uniformly
in the graph it turned out that the ops
it the the wash the composition is
concentrated on low levels the sum over
s of the carbon / squared times this the
the weight on the weight of a s let's
say is upper bounded by the volume this
is the variance of F okay so you did it
and here the constant only depends on
number I mean maybe I should stress the
fact that this is not true if we we
consider some quantity which seems with
which looks a bit like the effective
resistance which is the time the first
passage time of first passage
calculation if I call tuv the infimum of
our all flows from u to V of the sum of
yes sorry / e of our of e times the
absolute value so I put one or instead
of two then this is the the first
passage time from u to V and we know
that this is not true
this is not true because on Z this
cannot be true because on GD we know
that the violence in fact in on GD for
first passage decorations we know that
this quantity is larger than the
violence of is large with respect to the
variance of you because we have a lower
bond of the vials of which is of the
order of just distance from u to V of a
log of the distance and this is
essentially of the order of this of the
distance from u to V so putting a square
here changes completely the behavior of
the world's decomposition but it is not
very very surprising because in the wash
in it when when when you are looking at
the flows the optimal flow can change
very smoothly where the path cannot
change a reason resource why not you
maybe it's not convincing sorry okay so
we will show this F F know is the
effective resistance and we will show
another thing which is important for
Goshen approximation we will show that
the DL to norm of F spent on sets of
large diameter can be controlled by the
violence of F times some some
coefficient here which can be written
like this so to understand ir e is the
optimal current from e minus 2y plus so
you take every edge e in the graph you
wonder you look at the optimal current
from e minus 3 plus so it's a it is a
current in the graph you you look at the
box a bowl of theta of rogers l over
around e and you wonder what is the
energy dissipated by the optimal current
for me- replace
on that on that bar so it is natural for
instances it is from GD to believe that
when the L goes to infinity this will go
to 0 but so this one will be good if
this can be true uniformly in e and r so
what will be the consequences 1 the
first inequality will give it that the
valence is in fact of the same order of
of the the upper bound of the Ponca in
equality which is essentially of the the
mean of the sum of I r4 v so this is
this so you asked what kind of one of on
the violence we have so we obtained I
open this it it doesn't fit me what is
the author of this ok but so we will we
will look after at this later and the
second thing is that if I can prove that
alpha is small then on a bat on a graph
with bungee degree the sum of FS of s of
small diameter is the sum of local
independent random variables and then F
will be approximated by some can be well
approximated by a normal gaussian random
variable under linda bug type condition
so just for these two results in fact
one can replace the electricity
condition by a condition in the moments
on RV and COV but after that afterwards
I i will have I will need stronger I
will really need the additive
electricity hypothesis so I will prove
I will show you how to prove one too so
the idea is the same for both risk for
both inequalities we need to bound the
l2 norm of Delta Y Delta e prime F
squared so recall that Delta Y Delta e
prime is a kind of second partial
derivative with respect to our of our V
prime so let us look at an F is the
effective resistance let us look at the
first derivative so this is easy to see
that it is the sum sorry the first
derivative with the partial derivatives
with respect to our V equals the value
of the optimal flow at E squared if we
want to to differentiate rice so we
differentiate the this optimal flat e
with respect to another and another
rather another resistance and this makes
appear the optimal flow at a prime x ir
e prime of e over our V prime Oracle
that I'll call you that this is the
optimal flow from a prime minus 3 plus
so we have a formula for the second
derivative okay and because okay partial
derivatives can be both can be done in
both order then you see that what we
obtain here is necessarily equal to this
just by by exchanging the roles of e
primary and in fact the fact that this
quantity here equaled this quantity here
is known it is called the reciprocity
logo in the network electrical network
theory
so the first to market that this
equality explains why i say that the
upper bound of the Ponca high inequality
is of the order of the sum over II of
the mean of is to the fore of it okay so
just because this is the essentially it
is there a partial derivative and to
understand this just just to explain why
how we obtain this it is maybe i will do
it quickly just in fact you you start
from the northern cycle or suppose that
you are on a finite graph then I is
characterized by the northern side and
cycle low and so you differentiate the
node low this tells you that partial
partial I are divided with respect to
our V prime is in fact the sources but a
soft less flow and you differentiate the
the node low the cycle oh sorry and this
makes appear an additional term when you
when when one of these edges is the edge
with respect to which you are
differentiating but anyway using this in
fact you recover other cycle laws and
not laws for essentially the partial the
partial derivative of the flow and the
intensity is is given is given by this
if the intensity is I re prime over V
Prime and you you will you see that
there is uniquely a voltage drop along
the edge across which you are a river
you are
de-rating about or with respect to which
you are derivative so this is this
explains this means this explains the
appearance of Sauron of this factoria
so now suppose that wash maybe I should
recall you what is one so one word what
is we want to prove that the altoona day
in the wash in the world system the the
second moment of the Cardinal of S is
upper body is bounded so first I use the
formula for the second second partial
derivative of F so this tells me these
we want to separate we want to some
other all couples I e prime which are
different where is different from a
prime so I want to separate these two
terms I just choose a to a be like the
nice crab of this square are very
important in equality and here sorry
here in this these two songs are
completely symmetric so I just have to
care about one okay here in fact i use
the fact that i use the reciprocity law
so i obtained i I just have to care
about this term seen this does not
depend on a prime I obtained this and
this this if I if I put some the
resistance of e prime in front of this
term I exactly obtain the energy
dissipated by the unit flow from e minus
2ax plus and this the this is the
effective resistance if i if i sum over
all LG z prime this is the effective
resistance between if a minus and a plus
over the whole network but it is always
less than the resistance between e minus
and a plus I know I always can take a
flow which goes to piddly from e minus
2ax plus x by sending one on this edge
and do as well so this is upper bounded
and this only depends on
lambda i obtained i obtained this with
that and we already saw that this is of
the same order of this of the upper
bound in the Parker inequality to
directly energy and so we what we
obtained here when we interchange the
zooms with the fact you know Delta Delta
e prime F cancels all FS 4s with do we
do not contain e or do not contain a
prime so DC is essentially this in fact
is the sum of Rs of Cardinal arrest
times cardinalis s minus 1 times it so
we obtain an upper bound of the second
monument by the first moment of the
Cardinal RS in the new workspace and
this is this can be obviously this kind
of this implies obviously the kind of it
notably with there is no stability in
the in the in the title of my talk
notably this shows that that the
effective resistance is always nice
stable in the sense of venom in decline
in charm uniformly no stable uniformly
new env and n in the graphs
the proof of two is essentially the same
the in fact the only points22 to notice
first is that if I want to bond you
upper bound the sum of the diameter of s
the sum of the l2 norm of X F s squared
of sets s which have large diameter
larger than L i canna per bond this by
this this zone the sum over all copper
II prime which are distance at least I
air of the sum of our old sets s which
contains at least see any prime of del
Toro's the wash not because when set SS
diameter larger than L you can find a
couple of edges en e prime belonging to
s which are distance at least L larger
than 10 so and this equals this and you
you do the same trick as before and so
the only thing to notice is that the Sun
assume that you are doing here is really
symmetric in EN e prime so that you can
do the same trick as before and what
appears then if if I assume if I spit
this zoom into the zoom over II and the
zoom of a ologies a prime which are far
away from from E and I I just upper bond
then the sum of a prime by all possible
values over en and over all resistances
I get the I get the second inequality
okay so I will well maybe I will go a
bit faster but on this just to
understand where the Linda bail
conditions in intervene we if I call
know about the normalized effective
resistance and I just I want to throw
out all FS which are 4s which are which
have large diameter so i define jfl the
sets s speech shaft diameter less than
element which are unknown empty off
there is mistake here should be there
should not be an l2 norm here it's just
the sum of ffs of all those sets s which
count and are about its normalization so
there is a result by changing shower for
instance there are the result that the
one bite challenge are really good and
which bound the distal infinity norm
between the the PDF of the normalized
Gaussian the standard Gaussian and the
PDF of RL by the constant which will
depend only on l and and the times
something which is the sum of the of the
l3 norm of f s 2 3/3 hub the the
standard deviation of our l-222 one half
to two three so the point is that if if
the these these quantities are well
spread out this will be small okay so
this is where the lindo bag type
conditioner comes from and it turns out
that you can relate these quantities
when s is a bounded cardinality
you can relate these quantities but 2's
has here in jail fellas husbanded
diameter but if as its offices to have
s-off bonded the cardinality to relate
to upper bound this norm x norm which is
easier to to compute which is the the
projection of F on only the watch
subspace induced by the sets the single
attack the singleton e and this is upper
bounded by the here f e okay it's on the
first level of the wash system on the
first level almost nothing moves you you
only f e only depends on us up on our
feet so there is very little variance
here and okay so this is a verb mountain
valley by this so what we obtain is an
open bond of this kind and so if you can
if you can show that this is really
small than you have then you will have a
question approximation for RL and on the
other hand if you can show that our file
is small then use you know that the
original our bar is closed to all 22 to
the one where we only kept the important
the small-diameter sets so to summarize
there are two conditions for version
approximation alpha avail small and the
linear back type condition so I yes 10
minutes okay so i will I want it so this
slide is just to say that why I cannot
adapt this setting to the box in fact so
the optimal flow on the box it
corresponds to a voltage which is
constant on which are the the additional
no sorry
ir e is it was ok e to it was the
optimal flow on the graph on the
contemporary off between a minus and a
plus so there is an analog and the box
when we differentiate the effective
resistance on the box and so on which
would be a voltage but with the
additional condition that it is constant
on a n and on GM so either you consider
a n and ZN as single vertices and then
this will be really harmonic but we will
not have a bounded degree graph and so
everything breaks down either you don't
consider a and he and a singer vert
vertices but then if you are e is not
necessarily a harmonic on the whole box
outside of anything so there is a
problem here and where I i will skip say
essentially III do not exactly know how
to to prove I only know how to to show
for instant that the the analog of
alphaville will be small but only
uniformly of edges which are far from
the boundary and we have a problem at
the printer okay the more important
remark maybe I did since I was on a
general graph I did not make any
assumption on the translation invariance
it doesn't hurt it doesn't have any
sense so and my resistance is odd were
just supposed to be independent notice
three iid in fact on the on the box if
we only to pull that the resistances are
independent it is not necessarily true
that we have crush on approximation and
this is due to to the fact that there
may we can arrange elliptic resistances
in a way that attracts some part of the
flow to which is it will it will not be
a positive fraction of the flow but it
will be two larger and it will have the
effect that it will have the following
effect in fact you you put edges like
this which have small resistance ok and
then edges the edges in green have large
resistance and again small resistance
large of the stands ok this will attract
a part of the flow here and what what
will be true on the kind of of of of
network is that here the voltage will
behaves will behave suppose that we
Center this around the origin the
voltage will behave like x over N to
some power let's say eta will depend on
the on the difference between the under
cushion between the resistance is in
blue in the resistances in green and
what will be true is that the the
absolute value which goes from an edge
the central edge let's say 'i will be of
the same order as the whole l for norm I
phone number for so this is the order of
the vines and so a positive part of the
violence is is owned by this edge here
and so if you have if you have a
constant value e resistances you will
still see in your filtration that
that kind of been we behavior okay is
the same sure if you just fix all the
edges to one constantly they just take
one to be very origin the edges the
green edges are large and the blue edges
are small what happens if I justice all
day or all edges to one and one edge
burner II know it will edit this
everything will be fine so what is what
do you this is a here I do not prove
anything I say that I said that when in
fact I do i do not have a full proof of
this but it's a there is continuous well
known counter example in the setting of
harmonic analysis which says that which
shows that you that you can have a
harmonic voltage which has which will
have this behavior and the behavior is
that the the flow going through the
central edge here to the four had the
same order of the sum of all ages of IR
for the gosset approximation really does
not always this does not totally showing
the Gaussian position is on hold how did
you that the this will not impact
because I mean if the influence of an
edge is of this or their influence of
edge is of this order and when I move
resist the resistance across HD by a
constant factor it will it will have an
impact on the fluctuations which will be
of the order of the typical fluctuations
so if I it it would be a miracle to have
exactly the good shape of random
variables which will do that it will
still stay goshen example
fluctuations of the order of operations
now because in your if everything is one
outside and here you just have one
banner year on the Bible the the the
optimal flow will just throw a very
small portion of f1 through your edge it
will float one over N to the D minus one
for your edge essentially this is not
true here okay I think so i just have
the or minute to talk about the taurus
so let us do quickly i will only stress
the the main differences so when if we
have in violation invariance everything
will become simpler so we we take the
torus with iid resistances and we we
take a cut easier okay and vertical cut
here and we define the effective
resistance of the towers at the minimum
energy of a flow which is so less
overall sauceless flows I mean dystrophy
T equals zero everywhere but we impose
to the flow to have a net flow through a
zero which is one so in a sense for that
this is satisfied for by a path which
goes through the hole okay like this so
in a sense we force the the optimal flow
202 to go through to go through the
whole to go run the whole then
essentially i mean the the basic theory
remain that there is a uniquely there is
a unique minimum the minimum is uniquely
attained and the resistances of the same
order as before and here we can show the
theorem
and I so I would on so I'm late so I
will only explain one thing just very
quickly so the analog of alpha L before
is this kind of thing I want uniform in
n to have some kind of energy dissipated
which goes to zero and the main the main
thing is the following if you so because
of translation invariance you only have
to focus on one fixed edge and so that
this is the show and seen from a fixed
edge the torus converges to Z D ok
incense and here thanks to uniqueness of
currents and to this convergence of GD
two of the Taurus to GD you can show
that what played the analog of the
partial derivative of the of the second
partial derivative of the of the flow on
there on the grid under a general air on
the box here it will convert to the
optimal flow from e minus 3 plus on GD
so next there is a compactness argument
which allows to show that day that this
is true but the main the main point here
which makes all everything work is the
uniqueness of currents on indeedy but I
will stop that
okay can you do something and I don't
think so I'm not sure yeah in the end I
in the end of the talk I wanted to say
that there in fact it so there is this
article by a bass cab salvi involved
which is really nice but so one
important drawback is that the only work
with the small ellipticity contrast that
they require that lambda is close enough
to one which in fact changes many things
due to some theory in harmonic analysis
but so when and they they announced a
result which without this condition so
this would be very very very nice okay
but they use a lot of homogenization
theory but I'm allowed the use part of a
dream is nice in theory and one
motivation of the of what I did was tow
plane result without too much hypotheses
of translation invariance and so on so
the first part is without but so on
cylinder I don't think I can I can do
something somehow related question is
sometimes you can oxybate the
function on the box for some sufficient
symmetric yes and that is what biskup
self-involved to do in fact if you
homogenization tells you that the you
can approximate in fact the the voltage
on the box by translation by in fact a
stationary version of the voltage and
but but the problem is that you 10
something at the level of the Gaussian
approximation you need the approximation
to be very strong to be in El phones and
in a sense because of this order picture
of the situation and this for this they
require for the moment the small
elliptic city contrast you know how
specific is some of these results are to
the effective resistance if I give you
some other optimization program or on
variables this is a more general
understanding of what makes centrally
with your mold here or it's very unique
well no well I think that probably there
is a way to generalize part of part of
it but well first the there is this
counter example here which should that
you have you you need some convexity in
the in your organization strict
convexity but in but it at the beginning
we only differential twice and bound
that sort of the second in fact partial
derivatives by some product of the first
partial derivative times something which
goes to zero in fact this is essentially
what is important and this could be
generalizing the number of settings
maybe in fact what and in this
hint for this is that the nolans result
uses an inequality by Chatterjee which
is what he calls a second-order pokhara
inequality and so in this context maybe
we should understand because Chatterjee
used his second topic area in equality
for all the optimization for other
approximation in optimization setting so
maybe